>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Ladies and gentlemen,
the 14th Librarian
of Congress, Carla Hayden.
[ Applause ]
>> Dr. Carla Hayden:
Good evening and welcome.
We are so please to see
all of you here tonight
for a very, very
special evening.
We have to start out with saying
aloha to students and faculty
of the University of Hawaii
who are watching via livestream
at the Center for [inaudible].
I knew I was going to do that.
Oceanography Research and
Education on the University
of Hawaii's Manoa Campus.
Please excuse me.
I am an arts and sciences
major and I knew that,
but we are so delighted to have
you here tonight and on behalf
of the Library of Congress,
it's my pleasure to welcome you
as we continue a wonderful
5-year collaboration
with the Daniel K.
Inouye Institute
to commemorate the life,
the legacy and the values
of the late Senator
Daniel Inouye.
As many of you know, he valued
friendship before politics;
country before political party;
and honor above all else.
He was a champion of freedom and
fairness, and it is a privilege
for us to celebrate his
legacy this evening.
This event is made possible
by the generous donation
from the Daniel K. Inouye
Institute and we are grateful,
very grateful to have with us
this evening the driving force
behind his legacy,
Mrs. Irene Inouye.
[ Applause ]
We are looking forward to
next year's celebration
and we are hoping that all of
you will join us and be part
of a wonderful, wonderful
celebration.
I'm not going to call
upon the Director
of the John Kluge
Center, Mr. John Haskell
who will introduce the
lecture and the panelists.
[ Applause ]
>> John Haskell: Thank you.
And as many of you know, Dr.
Hayden has brought a new energy
and dynamism to the library
and that she's only been
here two years, a little less
than two years and many
of us are excited to
be a part of that.
As for the Kluge Center
itself under Dr. Hayden,
the center had re-centered
on its original mission
to be a bridge between
scholarship on the one hand
and policymakers and
interested public on the other.
Tonight's event exemplifies
that purpose.
Senator Inouye was a larger than
life figure here in Washington
and in his home state of Hawaii.
As a young man, after
the ban was lifted
on Japanese American
serving their country,
he enlisted in the Army
and served in a unit
of Japanese American
soldiers who fought
with extraordinary gallantry
in Italy, France, and Germany.
On October 21, 1945, in the
war's final weeks in Europe,
he was severely wounded.
He had just taken out two
German machinegun nests,
he lost his right arm.
He returned home with a
distinguished service cross,
a bronze star medal, two
purple hearts, 12 other medals
and citations, and not
incidentally a commitment
to bipartisanship that may
have stemmed from the long,
lifelong friendship he
formed in an army hospital
with another wounded veteran,
the future Republican Senator,
Vice-Presidential candidate
and Presidential
candidate, Kansas's Bob Dole.
After coming home and
finishing law school,
Mr. Inouye became Hawaii's
first representative in 1959
which was the year
Hawaii became a state.
Three years later, he
was elected Senator,
part of freshman class
inspired by President Kennedy,
which included President
Kennedy's brother Edward.
Senator Inouye served for
nearly a half a century
in the senate leaving
a rich legacy
that includes the National
Museum of the Native-American,
prominent service on the Senate
Watergate Committee, as well as,
on the Iran Contra
Committee and, of course,
on the Senate Appropriations
Committee which he chaired
in the last several
years of his career.
He was awarded the Congressional
Medal of Honor in 2000
for his military service.
After his death,
he was posthumously awarded
the Presidential Medal
of Freedom becoming
the first senator
to receive both of those awards.
Tonight, the John W. Kluge
Center at the library
and the Daniel K. Inouye
Institute present the 4th
in a 5-year distinguished
lecture series
to commemorate Senator Inouye's
commitment to bipartisanship,
moral courage, public
service, and civic engagement.
I would now like to
introduce our distinguished
panelists tonight.
First, E.J. Dionne who
writes about politics
in a twice weekly column
for the Washington Post
where he's worked since 1990,
he's also a government professor
at Georgetown, a visiting
professor at Harvard
and a senior fellow at
the Brookings Institution.
He's the sole author of 7 books.
Most recently, "Why the Right
Went Wrong; Conservatism
from Goldwater to the
Tea Party and Beyond."
He made his name as a major
political intellectual
with the publication of
"Why Americans Hate
Politics" in 1991.
It's not a new thing.
Ross Douthat joined the New
York Times as an op-ed columnist
in April 2009, previously
he had been senior editor
at the Atlantic.
He is the author of 4
books including this year,
"To Change the Church;
Pope Francis and the Future
of Catholicism", as well
as, "Grand New Party;
How Republicans can
Win the Working Class
and Save the American Dream."
Our conversation will be
moderated by Ann Compton,
former ABC News White
House correspondent.
Ann joined ABC News in 1973.
She covered 7 presidents.
She's traveled around the
globe and through all 50 states
with the presidents,
their vice-presidents,
as well as, first ladies.
We are delighted that
she can be with us.
After the conversation,
we will allot some time
for audience questions,
that would be
after some prerecorded
questions from students
at the University
of Hawaii campuses.
Please join me in welcoming
our distinguished panelists
to the stage.
[ Applause ]
Take a seat over there.
Thank you sir.
Thanks Ross.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Ann Compton: Good evening.
Thank you.
Aloha to the students who are
watching and to all of you
who have come tonight to talk
about the American dream.
It probably goes back
to, we hold these truths
to be self-evident "All men are
created equal, life, liberty
and the pursuit of happiness."
But where is the
American dream today?
Is there some; can there be such
a thing in a world as diverse
and deeply divided as
our times as these?
Senator Dan Inouye lived
the American dream.
In fact, he bled for it
as President Obama said
in his eulogy when
the senator died.
Ross I'm going to
start with you.
You wrote recently about
the American dream,
you said "It ain't
in California."
>> Ross Douthat:
But possibly Hawaii.
Right, well that, that
column was about, you know,
in certain ways I would
say that the State
of California has
become especially perhaps
in the Presidency of Donald
Trump, a kind of idealized view
of America's political
future for some liberals
and progressives and
democrats in the sense
that in California
you have a situation
where the Republican
Party as nationally
as pretty dysfunctional,
but unlike nationally is
pretty much irrelevant as well.
And in that sense,
California, you know,
and therefore California is
sort of not only as always sort
of on the cutting edge of,
you know, new technology
in Silicon Valley and the
movie industry and so on,
but is also seen as being
kind of on the cutting edge
of where progressive politics
could hope to be if the darkness
of the Trump era should pass
and the emerging democratic
majority should finally emerge.
And so, the column that I wrote
was basically saying that,
you know, while that might be
true if you look at the sort
of sociological landscape of
California, if you look at sort
of the social structure that has
emerged there, it doesn't look
at all what, like what I
think many progressives,
E.J. probably included,
would argue is the essence
of the American dream and we,
I mean we could sort of go back
and forth on what
that essence is,
but I think most people would
say that it has something to do
with a mix of kind of, you know,
a sort of strong
economically stable middle-class
and various forms of
sort of social equality
and upward mobility that sort
of intersect in different ways.
And the society that
California has even
under progressive governance is
a much more stratified society
in which for various complicated
reasons of public policy
and sort of overall
macro trends,
the middle-class has
basically been priced out
and so you have an
extremely wealthy upper-class
that has sort of entrenched
its privileges in various ways
through land use
regulations and restrictions
on building and everything else.
And then you have an
increasingly immigrant-base
working-class that
sort of serves as sort
of the service sector for that
economy and you have very little
in between and you have, once
you control for cost of living,
extremely high child
poverty rates,
extremely high racial
gaps, you know,
again whatever else the American
dream means; it has something
to with the equality of
the races and the quality
of opportunity and so on.
And so, the takeaway from
the column I guess was
that if this is the future
and if this is particularly
the future
that progressives are hoping
to build after the age
of Donald Trump should pass,
then there's still
considerable work to be done
if that future is going to sort
of dovetail with what, again,
I think traditionally
Americans have sort
of imagined the American
dream to be and to just
to personalize it a tiny
bit as I did in the column,
I'm from the East Coast,
but I was actually born
in San Francisco in 1979.
And I was born there
because my father was
from southern California and
he grew up in Santa Monica
in a period when that was a
kind of middle-class paradise.
His dad was a pretty
unsuccessful small businessman,
I think it's fair to say.
He ran a bicycle shop badly and
had various sort of salesmany
"Willy" Lomanish jobs
and my grandmother sort
of held the house
together, but they were
in no way what you would
consider sort of a, you know,
a major American successes.
They were sort of slightly below
the middle-class, and yet they,
you know, owned a small
sort of mission style home
in a neighborhood that was
close to the ocean and felt
like an earthly paradise and
were surrounded by people
with sort of similar
means and aspirations.
And, you know, there
were all kinds
of sort inevitable reasons
why that couldn't last,
but it's still notable that it
didn't last and if you go back
to Santa Monica now, all
those houses like the one
where my dad grew up have
been torn down to make way
for structures that are 2 or
3 times too large for the lots
that they sit on and all
cost 4 or 5 million dollars
and that world is gone.
And, you know, it was a
racially segregated world,
it was stratified in
all kinds of other ways.
There are all kinds of reasons
why it's never coming back,
but it's still notable that it
existed and then disappeared
and its disappearance is one
of the realities I
think underlying some
of our present political
discontents.
>> Ann Compton: E.J., is the
American dream even possible
in our society, in a political
society that's as deviant
as Washington is now,
as this country is now?
>> E.J. Dionne: Could
I just say a couple
of things first if I may?
One is, you know, whenever I'm
with my friend Ross I feel
obligated to defend Pope Francis
and now I will feel obligated
to defend California
and his grandfather.
[ Laughter ]
I just want to say, it's a
real joy to be at the Library
of Congress and I am, I got to
say I'm the son of a librarian,
so to have the opener of a
program like this be the Library
of Congress is for me higher
than having the President
of the United States here.
So, I want to a there.
[ Applause ]
>> Ross Douthat:
So, more true now
than in some administrations.
>> E.J. Dionne: Yeah,
I was going to say,
you could interpret that
many different ways,
so they're probably all
true, but so it's a real joy
to be here as part of
the in a way, program.
This is my second Inouye event
this year and I got to do a talk
in Hawaii and learn an enormous
amount about Hawaii politics.
So, it's great to start
with a little knowledge your
learning curve is awesome.
And, but I really realized that,
you know, when I was thinking
about the American dream,
Dan Inouye is part of that,
and that it's one of the
ironies of our history
that Japanese Americans
and non-Whites in general,
in Hawaii broke through partly
because of their service
in World War II and that
Hawaiian politics was
revolutionized by a group of
veterans led by Senator Inouye
who basically created the
modern Democratic Party.
And so, I just thank the folks
associated with Senator Inouye
for giving me this education.
Last, I just want to
say, I'm a huge fan
of Ross despite our
disagreements.
I teach a class at
Georgetown on media politics
and years ago I realized you
better start paying attention
to this online thing in
this media politics class.
And my first two guests
were a 23-year-old blogger
for the Atlantic [inaudible]
my first two blogger guests,
my first two opening to that
world, a 23-year-old blogger.
>> Ross Douthat:
I was surely 24.
I must have been at least.
>> E.J. Dionne: And I believe
you were, and I'll double-check,
and a 23-year-old
blogger name Ezra Klein.
>> Ann Compton: Oh, my gosh.
>> E.J. Dionne: And so,
I always tell my students
that my class is way ahead
of the mainstream media.
And I've always been grateful
to Ross for being there.
You know, the, I've
thought a lot this topic
in the last few weeks
thinking, you know,
about the event tonight and the
American dream is a really vexed
idea that, you know, it can be
seen as a kind of romantic view
of what opportunity is like
in America given the groups
over our history who have
been excluded from it,
but the other side of it
and it may be most powerful
when it's used as a call upon us
to make our country what it not;
what it isn't yet,
but ought to be.
And two, sort of two uses
like that came to mind;
one was of course Martin Luther
King's "I Have a Dream" speech
and he was very explicit
in saying
"It is a dream deeply rooted
in the American dream."
And as you suggested
at the beginning,
he too invoked the Declaration.
I have a dream that one day this
nation will rise up and live
out the true meaning of its
creed we hold these truths
to be self-evident that
all men are created equal.
But it can also be
used as a critique.
Many of you know probably
Langston Hughes' most famous
poem, "What happens to a
dream deferred does it dry
up like a raisin in the sun?"
And what I had forgotten is
how that poem ends which is
"What Happens to a Dream
Deferred" the last line
of the poem is, "Or
does it explode?"
And it's just sort of a reminder
of what can happen when we hold
up these ideals and then
don't live up to them.
I was trying to figure out
what is a definition of this?
And I think one take is that
hard work leads to success.
That's one kind of definition
of the American dream.
The other is that the next
generation will do better
than the previous generation.
Those are sort of vexed now.
We still believe, we're
still optimists even
after everything
we've gone through;
61% of our population
according Gallup believes
that young people will live
better than their parents,
but there has been a decline in
some of these number, you know,
in at the right at the
turn of the millennium,
74% of us believe that people
who work hard can get ahead
and that fell to 58% at
the end of the recession.
And to go to just briefly to
your point, can we achieve this
in a country so divided?
It strikes me that we
will have trouble sort
of creating public policy
that might move us forward
because we are so
deadlocked about what
that policy should
be, but even our view
of the American dream is
now shaped by partisanship.
The optimism that people had
in that Gallup survey when up
because so many republicans
switched from negative
to positive after President
Obama was out of office.
That's on the one side, and
the other side there was a;
I was looking at a
study of millennials,
at the end of the Obama years
African-American millennials
were much more optimistic, were
much more likely to believe
in the American dream than
White millennials were.
So, it's our view of this has
shaped partly by politics,
partly by race, partly by
where we sit in this society.
>> Ann Compton: You know,
you touch on exactly what the
Kluge Center does and that's
to connect thought to action,
and those two common measures
of the American dream as you've
just both just pointed out,
are we, are you better
off than your parents were
and the other is,
do you own a home?
Ross let me start with you and
then the Kluge answer would be
and what we ought
to do about it?
Are you better off
than your parents?
Are your kids, although
they're small now I think,
going to be better off than you?
And are there things that as a
society you think can be done
to push that along?
>> Ross Douthat: I mean, on
the personal front we just went
through a really bad real estate
transaction sort of exacerbated
by illness, no it's
a, it's a bad time
to make that assessment.
I wouldn't want to,
I wouldn't want
to apply our particular
situation for the country
as a whole, but I,
but to generalize.
>> E.J. Dionne: I hope this
increases your appreciation
for regulation of real estate.
>> Ross Douthat: That, that
and the speaking engagements
and Honoria as well are
incredibly important.
But I, I mean, I think
generally, You know,
there's no question that over
the last 40 years on this sort
of "are you better off
than you parents" question,
the country has gone through
a long period of stagnation.
Tyler Cowen who, you know,
E.J. knows well is an economist
at George Mason and wrote a book
called "The Great Stagnation",
basically sort of
describing this long period
where the median income which
is, you know, as good a way
of sort of measuring you
know the sort of heart
of American life as any,
the median income basically got
stuck and so it wasn't a period
of collapse, it wasn't the
Great Depression, you know,
we slowly we've had obviously
a severe recession recently.
We've slowly climbed back from,
but basically it's a story
of a society where the economy
for most people seems kind
of stuck and where you aren't
sort of, you're doing okay,
you're not in poverty, you know,
you have Welfare State Programs
that sort of stabilize
things during recessions,
but what we had gotten used to
during these wave of expansion
in the, you know, during
the Industrial Revolution
and then again in
the post war boom,
just hasn't been
there for most people.
And over that same period
you've had a kind of hollowing
out of community
in American life,
because I think another aspect
of the American dream is,
you know, if you go back to
sort of the people who came
to visit America in
the 19th-century,
Alexis de Tocqueville
most famously,
and sort of what they remarked
on about American
life they said,
well you know you have
a weaker state here
than you often do in Europe.
You don't have an
established church.
You don't have a lot of
the big institutions,
but you have this incredible
community spirit often rooted
in religion, but also just sort
of rooted in civic engagement
in other things, you know,
from sort of the, you know,
New England Town Meeting through
the culture of the Midwest
and so on, and that has
obviously taken a hit
over the last couple of
generations and there's a long
and complicated argument about
how those two things intertwine;
how is the decline of
marriage rates and the decline
of church going and the decline
of you know bowling leagues
and all these things,
how is that related
to economic stagnation,
how the two fit together?
But that tangle is the sort of,
that's the central
policy problem I think.
It's sort of, you know,
how do you figure out one,
how to get the economy working
better for most Americans?
And at the same time, how do
you have a kind of, you know,
a sort of civic and familial
and religious sort of,
sort of a knitting back
together of the social fabric?
And, you know, we have a lot
of evidence from the last 5
or 10 years that this,
you know, that things,
things have actually gotten
worse in a lot of respects.
I mean, the opioid
epidemic, you know,
suicide rates have gone up.
You know, you have a decline
in American life expectancy
for the first time and
all, that's you know sort
of concentrated in
particular parts of the country
and especially to E.J.'s
point, it seems to be a,
there's more sort
of social anime
and despair among White
Americans than among minorities.
There's more pessimism
among working,
in working class White America
than there is among
Blacks and Hispanics.
But whatever it is, that's,
that's the policy problem
and to the extent there's
a solution in, you know,
I think it lies somewhere
at the intersection
of the social and economic.
That we should be looking for
policies that basically say,
well on the one hand you
probably do need to find ways
to raise wages, get more money
into the hands of the middle
and the working class,
at the same time,
you want those policies to sort
of somehow create a
virtuous cycle with families
and communities and so on
and not just become the kind
of things that I
think, for instance,
a lot of Trump voters sort of
rebelled against the idea that,
well you know, your, I think
the Democratic Party has ended
up in a position
where technically its economic
policies are more popular,
but people don't like the idea
that well my community
has been hollowed out,
the jobs are never coming back,
but at least you
know I have Medicaid.
They liked more the idea that
Trump was selling of, you know,
you're going to get the
jobs back, things are going
to be the way they were
before and I don't think
that was a completely honest
sales pitch, but it spoke
to a challenge that I think
both parties haven't been able
to meet that combined
idea of sort of solid jobs
and solid civic life
that slipped away
in big parts of the country.
>> Ann Compton: Yeah,
let's stick with some
of economics, go ahead.
>> E.J. Dionne: Yeah, I think we
agree to a significant degree;
I actually think one of the big
questions we need to grapple
with is whether that decline
in community, family breakup
and all of that is primarily,
conservatives tend to talk
about the causal era going from
there to economic conditions;
progressives tend to look at
economic conditions and say,
those are actually fostering
the decline of community,
the problems families confront.
And in some different
worlds it would be nice
to have a conversation
where I would continue
to argue the importance in
economic, but that progressives
and conservatives could say, you
have to care about the family
and civic life and you have to
care about the economic base,
but I think we've had
a real crisis, I mean,
measured by the numbers
in social mobility
since you can date it from
1973, you can date it from 1980,
but opportunity does seem to
be sticking more to people
in the upper middle-class
and above.
My colleague at the
Brookings Institution,
Richard Reeves wrote a book
called "Dream Hoarders"
about the upper middle-class
and that the, it's been easier
for the and that's not
even counting the extremely
privileged, this just is that
broader top of the society,
have been able to pass
along their advantages more
efficiently to their kids than
earlier upper-classes have been
and actually I discovered
Richard quoted something I said
over lunch in a book and
thank God he's a friend,
because he quoted something I
kind of liked to repeat instead
of some damn fool
thing I said over lunch
of which there were
many, but you know,
I said that I spend my weeks
writing columns announcing
inequality and my nights
and weekends increasing it.
You know, because as
somebody who is effectively
in the upper middle-class
whatever class I'm in somewhere
up there, I have an opportunity
to pass along benefits
to my kids, you know, for no
particular virtue of mine,
just because I happen to
be here and I am going
to do whatever I can to help
my kids as all of us will do,
but those kind of, you know,
the way in which
those advantages kind
of bundle together we
have less social mobility.
Second thing is,
we have had less,
a far less equally distributed
income growth that in the sort
of great period from World
War II through the mid70s,
1980 each quintile tended
to go up roughly equally.
We had not only a great
period of economic growth,
but a great period of
shared economic growth.
Since then, we have, it
has not been shared at all
that the middle and bottom
have stagnated and a lot
of the benefits have gone
to the top and especially
to the very top, and
what we're discovering,
and this is I think a question
Americans have to be tough
on ourselves about,
is that you know
in some ways the American
dream is now a sort
of Scandinavian social
democratic dream.
Which is to say,
that the societies
that have less inequality tend
to have more social mobility
and that there, you know, I have
my conservative friends always
like say I'm not for
equality results,
but I am for equality
of opportunity.
But what appears to be the case
is if you're class in incomes,
your class system and your
income distribution gets too far
out of whack, you
lose the capacity
for mass upward mobility.
So, again, this probably
reflects the difference
in our political view,
but I think we need somewhat
more egalitarian public policies
in order to produce
the degree of mobility
that the American dream
suggests we ought to have.
>> Ann Compton: Both of you and
I'm turning to education now,
both of you went to Harvard and.
>> E.J. Dionne: He wrote
a whole book about it.
>> Ann Compton: Well,
and I was going to say.
>> E.J. Dionne: His
about Harvard and mine is
about criticizing Harvard.
He joins the Catholic Church
and mine's a book
criticizing the Pope.
>> Ann Compton: Ross, Ross you,
it's been more than a decade
since you wrote so lovingly
of your Harvard years.
>> Ross Douthat: It was a
found; it was a found critique.
>> Ann Compton: I want you
to boil, boil the 300 pages
down for 6 to 60
seconds for this audience
and my question is, a decade
later any second thoughts
about your alma mater?
>> Ross Douthat: Oh, no.
I mean it's worse than it was.
I mean, no.
There haven't been, haven't
been second thoughts.
I mean, E.J. has
sort of teed this up.
I think effectively
what E.J. was talking
about in the Richard Reeves
"Dream Hoarders" phenomenon is
in a sort of more personalized
way, part of what I was trying
to get at in that book which
was called "Privilege."
And the argument was basically,
you know, sort of ripped off
from smarter people, the late
Christopher Lash among others
that the system of meritocracy
is not, does not, in fact,
tend to be democratic, right?
It tends to create a new
aristocracy that becomes
in a different way jealous of
its privileges that has sort
of different forms of capital
and so on and, you know,
SAT scores obviously matter
much more than ancient pedigrees
and so on, but that in
practice it recapitulates many
of the vices of older
aristocracies
and also developed certain vices
of its own like the belief that,
you know, well because
we're meritocrats we deserve
to rule unlike those old
aristocrats and so we don't need
to worry about no bless of
[inaudible] things like that.
So, that was sort of it in
a nutshell that basically
if you look around these
schools that are there to sort
of educate the elites, they are
in effect perpetuating an elite
that is itself sort of both
increasingly segregated
from the rest of
American society.
I mean, that's one of the
interesting things about sort
of the post-70s dynamic in
American life, that you have
if you go back 40 or 50
years and you look at sort
of the distribution of people
with Ph.D.s and JD.s these sort
of advanced degrees, they're
pretty evenly distributed
around the country.
You know, you have clusters in
each state sort of local groups
of academic elites and
legal elites and so on,
and then you flash-forward
to the present era
and they're much more
concentrated in these sort,
you know, the sort
of major East Coast
and West Coast urban
centers and then sort
of college towns scattered
around the country.
So, you have a kind of a
much stronger segregation
by education in the U.S. than
you had 40 or 50 years ago
and you have sort of fewer
local elites that are sort
of in touch with, you know,
Iowa, New Hampshire or whatever,
you know, whatever
state they come from
and you have this nationally
elite that's less in touch
with the country than it would
have been 40 or 50 years ago
and that's a dynamic
that, you know,
the Ivy League schools
and sort of the U.S.
; I mean, it's also
notable that the U.S. news
and world report
rankings, right?
I mean, when you think about
sort of what, you know,
the U.S. news and world
report rankings never change.
There's never, I mean they of
course, they change from year
to year sometimes it's
Harvard, sometimes it's Yale.
You can, schools can sort of
work their way up the University
of Chicago sort of changed
its submission policies 10
or 15 years ago and it's
climbed dramatically,
you know, things change.
But there's never, you know,
there's never a startup
university in the top 10
in the U.S. News and
world report ranking.
I mean, the newest university
that's ever there is Stanford
which was founded a mere, you
know, a mere 120 years ago
or whatever, and that in
itself I think is sort
of a significant statement
about what these sort
of meritocratic factories do.
They're there to sort of
protect their own privileges
by creating, you know, by sort
of reproducing the privilege
of the families and students
who attend them and, you know,
all societies have elites,
this is an inevitable,
an inevitable phenomenon,
but it's still notable
in a society sort of that has
such a democratic self-image
that people often think of
meritocracy and democracy
as being sort of
working hand in hand.
But, in fact, they often
cut against each other.
>> Ann Compton: Yeah.
E.J. I won't point out
that E.J. graduated
from Harvard before
Ross was born.
E.J. and I are.
>> E.J. Dionne: Oh God,
did you have to do that?
>> Ann Compton: Because I'm
even older than E.J. And,
but E.J. well go ahead and
defend not only Harvard,
but the idea that, that but the.
>> Ross Douthat: He
can't defend Harvard.
>> Ann Compton: That, that.
>> Ross Douthat: The Pope he
can defend but not Harvard.
>> Ann Compton: What
can the generations look
at the generations coming
out of the colleges now,
they've got that college degree
and they are crushed by the size
of their college debt?
>> E.J. Dionne: Well, I want
to; one observation I want
to make is that two of my very
favorite conservative writers,
Ross and David Brooks whom the
late Charles Krauthammer once
referred to as his
favorite liberal columnist.
God bless Charles.
I find that their critique of
American society is this close
to being radical and if we
progressives have done something
right both Ross and
David would be radicals
and not the conservatives
they are, because there is a;
there is a radical element of
that critique that I would,
I don't want to go on a
long defense of Harvard.
It's a wonderful institution
I happen to love it.
It was very important to me.
They have made efforts
both, you know, particularly
in recent years with both Larry
Summers and Drew Faust to try
to create more opportunities
for people of, you know,
sort of in the middle and at
the bottom, but it is still
about replicating an
elite and it's not;
the problem isn't Harvard.
It's system of meritocracy
where people come to believe
that they have earned all their
privilege even when they haven't
and that I think the
problem with meritocracy
as an idea is not that we should
discourage people from trying
to be smarter or trying to work
harder and all those things,
it's that people develop a sense
of dessert and then they look
down upon all kinds
of other people
who have not had the same
good fortune they had.
I found over the
years in my long life,
that you can tell a lot
about someone's world view
by whether they think of
themselves as totally self-make
or the product of good fortune.
Now, you know, we're all
obviously have mixture
of those things.
None of this is to not effort
or the hard work people do,
or the fact that there
are indeed people who rise
from the bottom to the top,
but it is to say
not only is the idea
of being self-made a
biological absurdity,
but it also overlooks all the
opportunities that came your way
through chance, through good
fortune, through one teacher.
I grew up in a placed called
Fall River, Massachusetts
which is and who's
a Fall River parts?
Ah, and today by the way,
if I read my Twitter right,
is Lizzie Borden's birthday.
She is from my own town.
The most famous person in my,
from my home town I think.
But I was having Ernie Moniz
the former Energy Secretary
from Fall River and
I was talking to him
about Durfee High School
and my dad and my dad's,
one of my dad's best
friends was a physics teacher
at Durfee High School named
Mr. Delare [assumed spelling]
and Moniz looked at me and said,
"Mr. Delare is why
I do what I do now."
And it was a great high
school physics teacher
who inspired this working
class kid to become one
of the world class people.
So, that's good but somebody
like Ernie Moniz would
acknowledge no Mr. Delare
perhaps no career
like his and all
of us can tell those stories.
And so, in general, I share
a lot of what Ross said
about the problem of meritocracy
because it suggests to an elite
that they don't have any
obligation to give back ,
hat everything they earn they
earn because of their own,
you know, merit, you know,
grace doesn't enter into it,
luck doesn't enter into it,
somebody else's generosity
doesn't enter into it,
the help from the state
doesn't enter into it.
I'll just close with one of
my favorite tweets I ever sent
out which was during the
Republican Convention
and Chris Christie was giving
a speech where he talked
about his father going to
Rutgers a state university,
on the GI Bill a government
program and I just,
it was a friendly tweet.
It just said, "It's lovely
to see Chris Christie
acknowledge the role
of government in
his father's life."
>> Ann Compton: But, you
now touch, I want to switch
over to the overarching current
theme that affected my life
as a reporter for ABC News over
the course of 7 presidents.
The digital age has changed
so much in our society.
I look at not only how my kids
communicate, what they read,
how they communicate, but
also how Americans sometimes
withdrawal from personal
communications, how they rely
on information that
doesn't have the same kind
of good bone structure
of the reporting
and the Washington
Post, New York Times,
ABC News as it once was.
The digital age has changed
everything hasn't it Ross?
>> Ross Douthat: Yes.
Although, one thing it
hasn't changed is sort
of the economic landscape
to the degree
that people thought it would.
I mean, this is one of the
interesting, it's not a paradox,
but it is interesting
tension which is
that the digital age is sort of
its where everything has ended
up poured and other
areas of innovation
and technological
progress and so on,
have tended to whither a bit
as we've focused more and more
and more of our energy
and interest
on these tiny glowing screens.
And one of the, there's
an economist Robert Gordon
who wrote a book about, called
something like "The Rise
and Fall of American Growth."
And one of the points that
he made at the end was
that American growth
historically was incredibly
diversified, you know, the you
know you had growth in energy
over here and you had growth
in construction over there
and so on, and the digital
age has been much narrower
and there's a sense
in which it sort of,
it sort of recapitulates
in the economy what it does
to us psychologically.
It's sort of, it's a colonizer
of our psyche, thief of our time
and focus and attention, and
it's also sort of absorbed a lot
of I think sort of
energy and interest
that 50 years ago would
have been more diversified,
sort of spread out more
across the economy.
So, that's the only
counterintuitive point
that I would make on the
changed everything point.
I think to the question,
I mean what this is sort
of the big unanswered social
question of American life
over the next 40 or 50 years,
is to what extent is digital
media a potential substitute
for the decline of
community that E.J. and I,
I think generally agree is a
real problem in American life.
To what extent is, you know,
is social media and sort
of the communities that form
online sort of are substitutes
for the decline of,
you know, Elks Lodges
and churches and so on?
To what extent is online
dating an effective substitute
for you know the decline of
real-world sort of institutions
that brought men
and women together?
Or to what extent is
it a sort of assimilate
from a hollow substitute
basically?
And since I'm, you know,
conservative and critical
and pessimistic, I tend to
sort of emphasize the extent
to which it might be a sort
of hollow substitute that,
you know, that of course
people do fall in love online
and make friends online
and all of these things,
but very often they
find themselves
with online friends and,, you
know, a sort of online life
that seems to make teenagers,
for instance, more depressed
than their peers
were 20 years ago.
But, but we're really
early in the experiment
and you could argue
against me and say,
well thee things are just
getting off the ground.
People are just learning
to live online.
It's a disruptive technology.
People will get used to it
and then it will actually supply
the community that we need,
but that's, that's the
question I think that is hanging
over American society
and obviously not just
American society going forward.
>> Ann Compton: Alright, Ross.
>> E.J. Dionne: Especially
for people younger than me.
>> Ann Compton: E.J.
>> E.J. Dionne: You know, it's
funny when I think about it.
I know so many younger people
and even some older people
who are, you know, who
are, who lost their spouses
or got divorced who have
met through online dating
and I sometimes wonder, well
that's probably more sensible
than meeting in a bar.
You know, which is better and
that people come to each other
with more information.
I met my wife on the D.C.
Metro and so I always
like to say I really
am a liberal.
I owe a great deal to
public transportation.
>> Ann Compton: Transportation.
>> E.J. Dionne: And an
agency of government.
We've been together a longtime.
The, I want to give it a
way the conservative answer
that I thought actually you were
going to give, which is nothing
about this technology
changes human nature.
That human; I think one of the
things Ross and I broadly agree
on is that human nature
is something given.
You can alter the way
people behave and perhaps
over time this effects the
way our consciousness works,
but it doesn't change that and
there's a lot of me that wants
to fight the idea that
technology alters us in all
of these radical
ways and yet some
of the change is undeniable.
And so much of it is
how we educate ourselves
to use this media.
So on the one hand,
the parody is
of people whose entire friend
groups are sort of online,
people don't talk to each other
face-to-face, but the other side
of that is online is often a way
in which people organize
themselves
for actual social encounters
to create opportunities
for face-to-face engagement.
Neighborhoods have
used technology to try
to bring people together.
If you think back to
the Obama Campaign in 08
which was very innovative,
a lot of it began online,
but ended with a
door knock, you know,
which is the most
intimate kind of you know
of a real human connection
being made.
Where I do think it will,
and I agree with Ross.
I think I'm influenced by
the same book, that we have
to ask ourselves does this
take; has this technology
yet changed our lives the way
the invention of the light bulb
or the automobile or the
telephone did or not?
And we could probably
debate some of those things.
What I do worry is will we be
innovative enough as a society
to replace all the jobs
that are potentially lost?
And while we've been talking
about automation since the 50s
and 60s, you sense
that that process
of job destruction could be
sped up and the question is,
will we be innovative
enough to create work
or will the economy create work
that will make up for that?
I'm reminded about great
Walter Reuther story.
I can't remember if it was
Ford or GM, I'll say it was GM
and the GM guys take
Walter Reuther the head
of the United Oil Workers Union
into a brand new, you know,
plant with all these
robots and machines.
Then Carson, the GM guy says
to Walter Reuther "You know,
these robots won't
be paying UAW dues."
And Reuther shot back, "Yeah,
and they won't be
buying GM cars either."
And I think that is a kind of,
you know, struggle we're going
to have going forward.
>> Ann Compton: I want
to ask one more question
before we open this
up to questions not
only from the audience
but from the students in Hawaii,
I was, it was suggested to me
that one of the good ways
to look forward here,
especially since both of you
have connections to and contact
with the younger people,
young students, journalists
and how are millennials
rethinking their own view
of the American dream?
Let me start with you E.J.
>> E.J. Dionne: Um.
>> Ann Compton: Or do
they think about it?
>> E.J. Dionne: Well,
there is some evidence.
I've talked to political
pollsters who have said
that the American dream idea
does not resonate with younger,
with younger voters with
younger Americans in the way
that it does with
older folks; although,
this data on the difference
between you know
African-Americans and Latinos
on the one side and Whites
on the other suggests there's
an even more complicated story.
But I think there
is a, you know,
in you know I have three kids
in their 20s and I have talked,
I don't know I've been
teaching now for 15 years,
so and I've had really
awesome students, and my sense
from them, so I'm not going
to make it any more than that,
is that there is for good reason
somewhat slightly less optimism
about their way forward.
They feel like they have had
difficulties thrown at them
that were not thrown
at someone my age.
You know, I was born in 1952 and
sort of reached adulthood in one
of the most extraordinary
periods of growth
and opportunity in
our country's history.
And actually during the 90s,
so when my kids were
little I thought,
gee maybe by delaying having
kids I really lucked out
and created, you know,
brought my kids into a world
that will match that
great period
and then you know came
you know 9/11, the wars
and then the economic collapse.
And so, my sense is that there's
still a lot of, I mean you know,
young people have not lost
a natural sense of optimism
but I think there is a stronger
sense of you know the obstacles
that they face and not the easy
sense that we got of, you know,
when I was a kid that
America was literally sitting
on top of the world.
>> Ann Compton: Yeah.
>> E.J. Dionne: You know, and
you think of all that optimism
and call to service
in the Kennedy years
that this is something
different.
>> Ann Compton: Ross
takes a swing
at this before we
actually get questions.
>> Ross Douthat: Sure.
I mean, first think
E.J. is right.
I Think that there,
you know, if you think
of the millennial generation
as people who came of age
after 2001, you know, we've
been talking about a 40
or 50-year stagnation,
but really the worst
of it economically even
setting aside war and terrorism
and everything else, has
been the last 15 years
and if that's your experience
of sort of entering adulthood,
entering consciousness as
an American and son on,
you are naturally going to
be I think more pessimistic
about your prospects because
your prospects have been worse,
worse by far than
your generation
and somewhat worse
than my cohort.
Although, 9/11 happened
my senior year of college,
so there was you know, there
was a decline in the number
of consulting jobs that my
fellow meritocrats were able
to take.
That was our great tragedy.
Thank you for laughing
at the irony rather
than taking me seriously.
But I would also say
I think this to try
and weave together the community
and the internet questions
a little bit, I mean,
one of the striking
things about millennials
and whatever we're
calling post-millennials,
is that in certain respects they
are the best behaved generation
in modern American history.
If in term of drug use, teen
pregnancy, car accidents,
all you know, the sort
of laundry list of things
that people worry
about teenagers
and early 20-somethings
getting up to,
this cohort is incredibly
well-behaved.
But that, that sort of good
behavior coexists with a,
firs of all, a certain a
higher degree of unhappiness
which may be rooted in
economic factors, may be rooted
in sort of, you know,
sort of the digital age
and the anxieties it produces
and one of the reasons they're
so well-behaved is that you can
socialize online and so you're,
you know, you're less
likely to take the car out
and get drunk with your friends.
You're less, you know,
there's less teen sex
because perhaps there's more
sexting that sounds like a joke,
but it's actually
probably statistically not
and so you have this
question one, you know,
is the greater safety worth
perhaps the cost in happiness
and two, this connects
to the economic as well,
are millennials just sort
of delayed in you know,
I mean the basics of, you
know, the American dream
when you were a kid, you know,
you get married, you have kids,
you own a home, you know, you
own a car, you own a couple
of cars, if those sort
of visceral aspects
of the American dream
circa 1957,
millennials are getting
married at lower rates,
they are buying homes at
lower rates, they are driving
at lower rates, all of
these things that sort
of culturally we
associate with sort
of America normalcy
aren't happening in,
to the same degree.
And so, the question hanging
over the next 20 years will be,
are millennials going to
do all the same things
that E.J's generation did
just 10 or 15 years later?
Or is there are real shift?
Not in human nature, but
in human nature's response
to the economy, technology and
everything else that's going
to mean across the lifecycle
millennials are less likely
to have kids, more likely to
be single, more likely to live
in apartments that
suburban houses and so on?
And that's, again, something we
won't know for 15 years or so.
>> E.J. Dionne: Could I just
say one quick thing on that?
The other thing
about millennials that's
fascinating is they are a very
progressive generation.
They are probably the most
progressive generation
since the new dealers of
the greatest generation.
Now, some of that is
because they are a more
diverse generation.
That the, you know,
people who are say under 40
or under 35 are much,
a much larger percentage
African-American, Latino, Asian,
but even among White millennials
they are significantly more
liberal than other cohorts of
Whites and I, I tell my children
that you know when you are,
when my generation is gone
and your generation takes over,
this will probably be a
more progressive country.
The only problem with
that is I want to be
around to see the country when
you guys take over, so I'm going
to have to figure out
a way to solve that.
>> Ross Douthat:
Silicon Valley is working
on life [multiple speakers].
>> E.J. Dionne: But I do think
that they're more tolerant,
they're more, they are open.
I mean, there are some very
interesting characteristics
about them that make them
a potential political,
that may be harbingers
of political change
when they start voting in force.
>> Ann Compton: One of the
beautiful parts [inaudible]
of this program every year
is because we are linked
up to students in Hawaii and
they have offered the two
of you some really
interesting questions.
The first question we're
going to hear is from Shannon.
>> Hi. I am Shannon [inaudible].
I'm a communications student
at UH Manoa and my idea
of the American dream is a place
where people can live happy
and safely in a community
with friends and family.
My question is, what do you
think our generation can do
to make sure that we live
happy and healthier today?
>> E.J. Dionne: Oh, preach Ross.
Go ahead.
>> Ross Douthat: I mean,
my, my nonpartisan answer
as you can probably tell from
things that I've already said,
is that you should spend
less time on the internet.
That's, you know,
without getting into sort
of whether you should convert
to Catholicism or which kind
of Catholic you should
be, I mean,
that's you know that's
obviously important, you know,
and in a nonsectarian way,
I would say there is a lot
of evidence, it's not just
positive, but there's a lot
of reasonable evidence
that social life online is
potentially more likely to lead
to depression, unhappiness,
isolation, and less likely
to lead to healthy friendships,
healthy relationships,
healthy marriages, and so on.
And, of course, you
are, you know,
as I am still young
enough hopefully
to know this reasonably well,
of course, like you can't sort
of become a hermit and a
luddite and sort of opt
out of you know the social world
of young people is an online
social world, but figuring
out who to have, you know, your
relationships and friendships
as your connection to the
world at large mediated
through old fashioned
reality rather
than digital reality seems
like a really important step
that either today's
millennials or the generation
after them is going to have
to figure out to get to the,
to get to the point where
their relationship and all
of our relationship
to technology becomes
a healthy one.
So, that's yeah,
that's a nonsectarian.
>> Ann Compton: Great.
Let's take it.
>> E.J. Dionne: I mean,
I think I actually agree
with every single word you said.
That, and I do think that
sort of, I'm not the,
I love the technology.
I have all kinds of, I spend
too much time on my phone
like everyone else does.
I can find out if the Red Sox
are actually winning or not,
you know, instantly which is
very satisfying especially
this season.
The, you know, so I am
very much anti-luddite,
but I do think that,
again, there is evidence
that if you are involved
in politics, or service
or a religious congregation, or
sports teams, or a whole series
of other activities with other
people direct face-to-face,
that that's a helpful thing.
The other virtue I have
sort of toyed with a lot,
I thought about a lot, because
it's really complicated,
virtue is a virtual of loyalty.
And I worry a lot
about, on the one hand,
loyalty can be misplaced,
loyalty can demand you know the,
I mean I think the SS had
loyalty in its, you know,
its slogan which always reminds
me don't put too much on that.
On the other hand, I worry
about a society that's
lost the sense of loyalty.
Maybe this is, you know, from
you know, I'm from Massachusetts
where loyalties are so strong
that the most powerful,
you know, it's the old
joke about the version
of Alzheimer's you forget
everything except your grudges.
You know, if somebody was on
the wrong team, but I do think
that there is a; I worry
about the decline of loyalty
in a society from employer
to employee, from employee
to employer or our
loyalties to each other.
It's how do we strengthen
some of the bonds between us?
How do we stick with each
other when things get tough?
How can friendship be
demanding and not temporary,
not just something you
pass through and, you know,
geographic mobility makes
friendship more complicated
than it used to be.
>> Ann Compton: But
you can keep in touch
with each other across the.
>> E.J. Dionne: Well, right and
that's one of the advantages.
>> Ann Compton: With
much greater ease.
>> E.J. Dionne: And that is
where actually you
can be anti-luddite,
because you know it
strikes me with my kids,
my students that they maintain
their bonds in some ways.
>> Ann Compton: Yes.
>> E.J. Dionne: More
successfully than we did.
>> Ann Compton: Yes.
>> E.J. Dionne: That's a
good thing, but I just,
I sort of like people to try
to think about what is loyalty
and what does it demand?
Because that's something we
talk about much in our society.
>> Ann Compton: Oh,
you're right.
We've got two more
questions coming up.
The next one is from a
student in Hawaii, Jordan.
>> Aloha. My name is
Jordan [inaudible].
I'm a recent graduate of the
University of Hawaii at Manoa.
My idea of the American
dream is freedom.
My question for you is, what
does freedom mean to you?
>> Ann Compton: E.J. what
That's just a small.
>> E.J. Dionne: This is like a
college interview in reverse.
>> Ann Compton: And we'll keep
this short because we want
to get to several
more questions.
>> E.J. Dionne: You
know, I think freedom is
about having the capacity
to effect the decisions
that are made that affect you.
Which means that freedom
is partly a social matter
and it's why I am a passionate
small "d" democrat and think
that institutions should be
democratized where they can be
and then I think, you know,
and then I think the First
Amendment, the freedom is sort
of described in the First
Amendment are a reasonable list
of what it means to be
free, but I will stop there,
because I should stop
and let Ross answer,
but these are a kind of
set of liberal freedoms
and I also think there's
probably another side of freedom
that I'm going to let Ross
describe that may have to do
with the freedom, how freedom
relates to responsibility and.
>> Ann Compton: Ross.
>> Ross Douthat:
What that, you can't,
you can't setup my answer
like that [laughter].
>> E.J. Dionne: Why?
I had to.
>> Ross Douthat: I
have not the freedom
to answer the question
my own way.
>> E.J. Dionne: I want
to control the conditions
on this stage.
>> Ross Douthat: So, yeah.
I mean, I will I guess
I'll try and wrap
in what E.J. was referring to.
I think the; where the
American dream is concerned,
I associate freedom and I
guess I'll sound, again,
a little bit lit like a
radical, but the freedom
in America is not to be
a prisoner of a boss.
You have a boss, people have
bosses that's you know that's
part of life, but I
always come back to a movie
that may be now is too old
for millennials to have seen,
but "It's a Wonderful Life" the
Jimmy Stewart movie from 1941
where he plays George Bailey
from Bedford Falls, New York.
And the whole idea in, behind
George Bailey is, you know,
he's a businessman, he
runs a Building and Loan
and he's trying to get
people into their own homes,
and there's old man Potter right
who's like you know the sort
of plutocrat of the town who
just wants people to rent
from him in his slums.
And, you know, the
dream of homeownership,
the idea of owning your own
home comes from this idea
of being having a kind
of rooted independence
where you are not a
prisoner of, in his case,
a landlord in the case
of you know being stuck
in a job you don't like, a boss
and so on, and that's, again,
in the American context
I think that is sort of,
that's the heart of
economic freedom.
It's the freedom to sort
of make your own choices
for your own family have the
resources whether it's the
money, the car to
drive, and you know,
light up for the territories
all of these sort of icons
of American life are
connected to that,
that version of freedom.
And then, to make the
conservative point, you know,
the question, the argument
that most American thinkers
in the founding era
and down to the 1950s
or 1960s would have
made is that, you know,
freedom is not the
same thing as license.
And freedom is confirmed
in responsibility.
You want to be free to be, you
know, free to be a moral person,
to be a good person, to be
bound by sort of community rules
and ideas and aspirations
and that freedom disappears
if it's just treated as a
freedom to do whatever you want
and that's the kind of society
that ultimately succumbs
to tyranny, maximal freedom
ultimately leads people to want
to submit themselves
to some authoritarian.
>> E.J. Dionne: I,
"every time a bell rings
and angle gets his wings", and I
just loves what Ross just said.
I once wrote a column on "It's
a Wonderful Life" as kind
of embodying the new deal ethic,
and I think what's intriguing is
in that movie is that moment
when George discovers what the
world would be like without him
and Bedford Falls
becomes Pottersville.
And what's so interesting
is that because of a lack
of economic autonomy and
well-distributed property,
Bedford Falls becomes
an immoral town.
It becomes a gambling, gambling,
prostitution, and to me one
of the things I love about that
movie is how it links the need
for economic justice to the
creation of personal virtue
and anyway, so my
wife we have hanging
and "It's a Wonderful
Life" poster
that my wife gave
me one Christmas
because I love that movie.
>> Ross Douthat: But it
is an economic freedom.
It's an, I'm sorry, an economic
opportunity that is rooted
in ownership rather
than dependence
which is this sort of it.
>> E.J. Dionne: But a
particular kind of capitalism.
>> Ross Douthat: Right.
Yes.
>> E.J. Dionne: But
a social capitalism,
a Christian democratized or a
social democratized capitalism.
>> Ross Douthat: Right.
>> Ann Compton: One
more question coming
from Nichole in Hawaii.
Aloha.
>> Aloha. My name is
Nichole Tam and I'm a student
at the University of Hawaii
at Manoa studying
journalism and Chinese.
I moved here 10 years ago
from Hong Kong with my family.
Our vision of the American dream
is good access to education,
as well as, the freedom
to express speech
and express the ways that
we can practice journalism.
My question to you is, do you
think we'll have the same access
to the freedom of speech
in journalism the way we have
today despite immigration
policies that's in
place right now?
>> Ann Compton: Immigration
policies in place right now
and whether the future
of freedom
of the press will be there?
>> E.J. Dionne: Well, I'm I
mean I sort of have two thoughts
on this that are
kind of intension;
one is I am genuinely
alarmed as, I think Ross is,
by the current administration,
it's attitudes toward the media.
It's, you know, it's constant
attacks, the media as the enemy
of the people that term the
president uses is a term
that Khrushchev of all
people banned in Russia
because it had sort of memories
of solecism and, you know,
I do worry about obviously
what's happened to the kids
in of parents who are
trying to cross the border.
I'm not sure I fully get the
link between the two except
that I, and that we've gone
through periods of, you know,
restrictionism in immigration
and more open borders
and we've kind of gotten
through those periods and I tend
to think Americans are
ultimately pragmatic
on this question and they open,
they open up the borders again
when they sort of feel that it's
in the interest of the country.
But I do worry about a
general attitude that's coming
from the government that
is authoritarian and sort
of a strong man if you
will view of the world
that is very disconcerting.
Having said all that,
I think that we're one
of the great things about the
U.S. is that we are really good
at correcting our mistakes,
you know, that Churchill line
that everybody loves, "Americans
always do the right thing
after first exhausting all
of the other possibilities."
And we're doing one
hell of a job
of exhausting all the
other possibilities.
>> Ann Compton: Let me get Ross
in here and then we're going
to open up with microphones
in the aisles for you.
>> Ross Douthat: Yeah,
I mean it's a weird;
the freedom of the press
issue is a weird one,
because on the one hand
it is extremely unusual
to have the President of
the United States, you know,
tweeting attacks on "Fake News"
and you know institutions
including my employer and so on.
At the same time,
the actual view
from inside the New York
Times and I think probably
from inside the Jeff Bezos
own Washington Post as well,
is that in practical
terms you know this is,
this is the Trump era has
been better for journalism,
maybe worse for everybody
else, but better for journalism
than you know the 5
or 10 years before it.
I mean, you know, the big
threat to the press in America
over the last 10 to 15 years
not to bring everything back
to the evils of the internet,
but has been the
internet's effect
on the media's business
model and the fascination
and obsession with Trump and
the Trump Administration and so
on has you know been a kind
of economic boom in many ways
to the press, and
at the same time,
whatever Trump himself may want
to do, his administration is not
at all in a position to I
think clamp down effectively
on the media in the
way that, you know,
you see in genuinely
authoritarian countries.
So, I'm of two minds.
You know, it's obviously
a bad thing that you know
to have a president sort of
delegitimatizing the media.
At the same time, there is a
kind of weird cabooky theater
to the whole thing where,
you know, it's Trump,
Trump attacks the New York Times
and the New York Times
subscriptions soar
and the next day Trump
is on the phone to one
of my colleagues you know
talking, talking to them
because you know he does that
all the time and so it's sort
of hard to get an overall
read on the situation.
>> E.J. Dionne: Could
I just quickly?
>> Ann Compton: Real quick.
>> E.J. Dionne: Um
>> Ross Douthat: I didn't say
anything about immigration, but.
>> E.J. Dionne: Yeah, no I think
that Trump has the interest
in Trump the worry about Trump
has been very good to a certain
for a certain number of
national elite organizations
that basically like the Post
and the Times and others who are
in a position to have
a national audience.
I still worry very much about
what's happening in journalism
at the local level where
the economic model.
>> Ross Douthat: Right.
>> E.J. Dionne: Where you still
have great reporters trying
to do everything they
can, but the number
of people covering state and
local government the number
and these papers don't
have the capacity
to build big national audiences.
>> Ann Compton: And that is
not in the last two years.
That has.
>> E.J. Dionne: That's a
long, that's a long problem.
>> Ann Compton: We have, it is
your turn now and we will try
to make our answers short to get
in as many questions
as possible.
Please raise your hand and we'll
have a microphone come to you.
There's one right in
the center here about.
>> E.J. Dionne: Vital center you
couldn't be more in the middle.
>> Ann Compton: Yes.
Yes, here's a microphone
coming to you from your left.
That's just the geographic left.
>> Is it working, yeah?
>> Ann Compton: Hello.
Thank you.
>> Is it working?
>> E.J. Dionne: We hear you.
>> Ross Douthat:
We can hear you.
>> Okay, great.
I'm Katharine Donato.
I'm a professor at Georgetown
School of Foreign Service.
I'm going to push you guys, both
of you on the immigration issue
because on the one hand a lot
of what you said is really
interesting, fascinating,
I agree on many points,
but I find your description
of the millennials and the
young people a little bit weak,
in part because as one
of you said or both
of you may have said,
this is a much,
this upcoming generation
not just the millennials
but the post-millennials
are more diverse
and certainly more
foreign-born but children
of foreign-born especially,
so I really would
like to hear a bit more
about the American dream,
freedom and immigration.
>> Ann Compton: Okay, run
back through a point or two
and do we have another
microphone out there
and another person, great.
>> Ross Douthat: Well,
I mean, so I'll try
and make two quick points.
The first is to try and
connect this all the way back
to the very first question.
Which is that one
of the questions
for American going forward
is does the society,
does society end up in this
dynamic that you do see more
in California than in
other parts of the country
where you have a
combination of ethic
and generational stratification?
And this is part of what drives
the Trump phenomenon and support
for Trump on the
right, but it exists
in extremely liberal states
as well where the combination
of declining birth rates
and largescale immigration
over the last 30 years have
created exactly the phenomenon
you described.
You have a younger generation
that is much more diverse,
much more likely to include
ethnic minorities and so
on than was the case
40 or 50 years ago,
coexisting with an older
generation that is sort
of richer and whiter
and obviously older,
and that is at the moment, a
source of it's a big source
of our political tension that
you have sort of these three,
you know, you talk about
sort of, we talked a lot
about class stratification,
we talk a lot
about racial stratification,
having that kind of sort
of ethnic divide between the
generations tends I think
to exacerbate class, you know,
when you have generational
divisions sort
of mirroring class and racial
divisions it exacerbates
polarization and
tension and so on.
And so, a huge challenge for
America going forward is,
you know, it's we haven't
dived that deep into policy,
but it is to figure out how
to take sort of take a sort
of a younger working class
that's increasingly racially
diverse and sort of advance
their socioeconomic interests
in a period where there is
this sort of generational,
intergenerational
alienation driven in part
by race and immigration.
That's just sort of a
macro level analysis,
I'm not providing any solutions.
The second briefer
point I'd make is just
to echo something E.J. said
which is that when thinking
about the immigration tensions
we're having now you do have
to recognize that there has been
this ebb and flow of immigration
across American history and the
period that we have been talking
about as a kind of sort
of a model of what a kind
of middle-class American
dream hero would look
like was a period of
extremely low immigration
that had been effectively
cutoff by the, you know,
not just somewhat racist
immigration rules in the 1920s.
And, so again, one
of the you know,
I've been what I
would describe as sort
of a moderate immigration
restrictionist
over the last 10 years,
and what, you know,
one of the arguments I've
made is that you've ended
up getting the kind of
extremities of Trump in part
because you had this very large
wave of immigration that sort
of brought America's
foreign-born population
up to levels we haven't
had in a 100 years
and neither political parties
took that seriously sort
of people who, you know,
who felt that it was
happening too fast,
and if you can't take those
concerns seriously you end
up in empowering more
demagogic alternatives.
I think the optimistic
cases that, you know,
you actually have
like if you look
at illegal immigration is
actually down over the last 10
or 15 years and in
part sort of some
of the Trump phenomenon
is a reaction to a trend
that has already crested, it's
sort of a delayed reaction
to much larger scale immigration
especially illegal immigration
in the early 2000s and as sort
of the culture internalizes
the fact that, you know,
the great wave of
Mexican immigration
to the U.S. is probably over,
you will have a lowering
of tensions around that
issue that will lead
to better policies
and fewer disasters
like the child separation
policy, but anyway.
>> Ann Compton: I'm going to do
one more quick question up here.
>> Ross Douthat: Sorry.
That was.
>> E.J. Dionne: I'm
going to sneak an answer
to your question
into the next one.
>> Ann Compton: That's good.
>> E.J. Dionne: I've
been asked to move on.
>> Ann Compton: Hello.
Yes.
>> Yeah, So, going
off of that theme
of increasing factionalization,
you alluded earlier to the idea
of other increasing segregation
among other lines particularly
among educational lines
especially thinking
of about the recent election
and how the political divide is
less so, but to in red states
and blue states more
between blue cites
and the red rural
areas, I'm wondering
if given the centrality
of that idea
to the American dream
the idea of a society
where the civic nationalism
is based in interaction
between people of different
educational demographic
immigration and other
backgrounds what policies
specifically do you think
could be undertaken to minimize
that segregation
and particularly
to have more integration
among educational
and other demographic lines?
>> Ann Compton: E.J.
>> E.J. Dionne: That, that is a
question that I think is central
to the future and that I don't
think we have good policy
answers to yet, because we
clearly have a situation
in the country where certain
regions are people magnets,
job magnets, investment magnets.
It's a figure of something like
85% of the venture capital goes
to three states and this
is not as you pointed
out correctly simply
red states/blue states
if you compare Downstate
Illinois
to Metro Chicago Upstate New
York to Metro New York City
or in my state, you know, the
mill towns like the one I grew
up in or Lawrence or
Fitchburg versus Greater Boston
and you saw this, you saw
this economic disparity
by region reflected
in voting patterns.
This is a huge problem
and economists tend not
to like regionally-based
economic proposals to try
to lift up one region, because
they see it as inefficient.
I've heard our economist
argue what you tend to do is
to benefit already privileged
people in those areas
and that the benefits
don't spread,
but I there are ways
of pursuing.
I think we do need to pursue
policies that are place-based
and ironically place-based
policies would help two very
different kinds of people on
opposite sides of the divide;
on the one side, inner
cities who have been hammered
by the industrialization and
on the other hand, smaller
and smaller towns and more
rural areas and factory towns
that have been hollowed out like
mine, and I think we just have
to find ways of doing that and I
also think we have to find ways
of making so-called
bad jobs better.
There was nothing that said
that working in a steel mill
or an auto mill was a good
job, except unions came along
and people got paid a good
wage, began to develop benefits
and we got to figure out how
to do that again for jobs,
for jobs in the service sector.
>> Ross Douthat: The best thing
that the Trump Administration
has done in this regard is
to tax Harvard [brief laughter]
and I'm not really kidding.
I think that there is,
there's a case for.
>> E.J. Dionne: Boy,
he's bitter.
>> Ross Douthat: Kind
of left; I'm bitter?
I've done very well
with my Harvard degree.
Eugene here I am
on stage with you.
The, I think there is,
there's room for a kind of,
for a kind of experimentation
that, again,
could cross left-right lines.
I think there's a better version
of Donald Trump that, you know,
when Amazon announced that it
was going to go on the hunt
for a new corporate
headquarters,
that better version of Trump
would instead of ranting
against Bezos on Twitter,
would have gotten on the phone
with Bezos and said, "Look,
I'm the President of
the United States.
I've got a lot of power.
I want to you know use my
soft power to prevail upon you
to consider going
to St. Louis rather
than greater Washington, D.C."
And, you know, as E.J. says,
that's the kind of thing
that economists hate
and it obviously sort
of smacks a little bit
of authoritarianism
and you could imagine it going
in disastrous directions,
but I'm open to the
idea that there are ways
that the Federal
Government can sort
of use soft persuasive
power around sort
of corporate leadership
and also, you know,
tweak and change tax
policies and do a bunch
of different things that could
treat some of these glomerations
of social and economic
capital as sort
of monopolies onto themselves.
The corridor is a kind of
monopoly in its own right
and if the Federal
Government suddenly announced
that it was going to
move a bunch of agencies
out to other parts
of the country,
that would be a small way of
sort of starting to breakup
that kind of cluster and I don't
think it would be a bad thing.
>> Ann Compton: Mrs. Airway.
We're going to close with one
last question from Hawaii.
The question comes from
a student named Harrison.
>> Hi. My name is Harrison
Betino [assumed spelling]
and I'm a journalism student
at the University
of Hawaii at Manoa.
My version of the American
dream is doing what you love
and being able to provide
for those who love you.
My question is; if we do what
we love, but we can't provide
for those who love
us, than how do we
as a society move towards a
place where that can happen?
>> E.J. Dionne: That man
should be a columnist either
that or a preacher.
That was a beautiful thing.
>> Ann Compton: It is and that's
why we want to end with it.
So, each of you use this as kind
of your closing argument
for tonight.
>> Ross Douthat: I mean, I'll
seek common ground and say
that the public policies we
should seek should be policies
that seek a little more economic
equality that we have right now,
but that seek it through by
targeting precisely the areas
that the questioner
is talking about.
Basically saying, we're going
to provide a little more support
for work and a little
more support for family,
and we're going to reorient the
welfare state so that, you know,
you have a little more money
when you're raising kids,
you have a larger earned income
tax credit or something like it.
If you're working a blue collar
job and it gets you to a place
that conservatives could support
because you're effectively,
you know, like the
GI Bill you're sort
of subsidizing hard work
and childrearing than most,
you know, the most conservative
things of all, but at this,
but you're doing it in a way
that does you know push the
society towards a slightly more
egalitarian income distribution,
because I think that,
that is the core question.
You should be able
to if you work hard,
you should be able to, you
know, get married, buy a house
and have a family and not
everybody wants to do that,
but lots of people do and
when America was working
at its best lots of
people were able to do that
and I think that's
a worthwhile goal
for policymakers today as well.
>> Ann Compton: E.J.
>> E.J. Dionne: The
idea of getting
to do what you love is
one of the, in a way one
of the great privileges of life
because there are so many people
who are essential to our lives
who are not necessary doing work
that they love, but work
that they have to do.
And so, I think the
question is, you know,
in the first instance
what are the ways
of increasing the chances
that people will get
to do what they love and
that probably has to do
with both access to
education on the one side,
but also I think a whole lot
more respect than we show
in our society to work that
does not necessarily require a
college degree, but
reflects commitment,
reflects craftsmanship.
I think that one of the
if you compare our economy
and our social attitudes
to the Germans I think one
of the things my friend Ed Luce
of the Financial Times has
written quite eloquently
about this that that society has
come to respect the work done
by those who do not
automatically fall
into some meritocratic elite
and has rewarded it accordingly.
And the I'm heartened
to hear Ross
for his egalitarian
approach and it pains me
that there are not very many
conservatives these days
who are willing to embrace
that kind of egalitarianism,
in a way I think more
conservatives did.
We look back and think
of Robert Taft as deeply,
deeply conservative and
yet he was in that era
of shared commitment created
by the New Deal and
by World War II.
He was willing to say that
the market all by itself,
the wardens of the market all
by itself will not guarantee
the good life for people.
And I'd like to see us
have a different kind
of political debate
where a conservative
like Ross might correct
me in my hope
or perhaps I have too much
hope in X government program,
perhaps I'd be more willing
to tax people than he would,
but yet we would share
a commitment to the idea
that you can't make the,
create the American dream
without individual effort,
but you can't create a society
in which the American
dream is possible
without some collective
action, some collective effort
and a real commitment
to each other
and not just to ourselves alone.
>> Ross Douthat: But the
irony it should be said
since we have both been
in different ways critical
of the President of the
United States tonight,
the irony of the Trump era is
that one of the many reasons
that Donald Trump was elected
president was his particular
sort of bludgeoning
and demagogic way he did
provide that kind of vision.
It was, you know, there isn't
actually necessarily policy
to back it up, but the Donald
Trump Republican vision was
closer to what you're
describing than the Paul Ryan,
Mitt Romney vision
4 years before.
That's, I think that's
something that the populism
of Trump is a sort of
crude grasp at that center
that you're talking about.
>> E.J. Dionne: Well,
what I would argue back is
what's particularly insidious
about what Trump did is
that it carried that promise
with policies that are actually
antithetical to that promise.
I always felt, for example,
that when you know progressives
and even moderates say to a
lot of folks who find at age 50
that they are not in a job that
provides them with the income
that they used to have
to support their families
and live a decent life, and
the typical policy person
who happens to be a college
educated comes along and says,
"Would you need more
training and education?"
And there's truth to that,
but I think that person has
every right to think what
that person is telling us is
we got to be more like them
and it comes off as, as
condescending and not
in any way genuinely empathic.
When Trump said, "I'm going
to bring back those factory
jobs and those coal jobs."
Of course he wasn't
going to do that.
I have a strong suspicion that
many of the people who heard
that and shared know that's
not true, but they had a sense
from that that he understood
the way they felt better
than the person who kept talking
about training and education,
so I during the campaign,
one of the best nicest
moments I had is I suggested
that the hat I wanted
to wear would say,
"Make America Empathetic Again."
And a very nice person in
the audience came up to me
and said, "I love that.
You're going to hear from me."
And I got this hat
and I got in my mail
and it was perfect
grappling of the Trump hat,
but it said "Make
America Empathetic Again."
And my son said "That's awesome
dad but you can't wear it
because he did too good a job
and it looks like a Trump hat."
But I do think that
we are, you know,
if our country dies it will be
because of our absolute
inability
to understand the suffering and
the pain of people unlike us,
and that the worse kind
of politics is a politics
that holds one group's pain
against another group's pain
and that's what we have
to find a remedy for.
>> Ann Compton: The conversation
tonight proves that the concept
of the American dream
is this conversation
that is never ending, tonight
true to the Kluge moto,
"We've given you
a lot of thought,
a lot of call to action."
Please thank Ross
Douthat and E.J. Dionne
for tonight's presentation.
Thank you.
>> E.J. Dionne: Thank you.
>> Ross Douthat: Thank you.
>> E.J. Dionne: Thank you sir.
>> Ross Douthat: Thank you sir.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc,gov.